vous
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande île madagascar
ses 27 millions d'habitants
19 et ni le grenier de l'océan à dire
depuis plus de 12 ans le département de
la réunion est engagé dans le
rayonnement de la francophonie à travers
ces visages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
on va traverser à 1h30 de vol une des
actions phare et le soutien au
déploiement des assistants d'éducation
en langue française dans les
établissements scolaires en temps normal
comme melvin
ils sont plus d'une cinquantaine sur
madagascar on est chez moi à tana j'ai
18 ans avant j'étais au lycée jules
ferry en bac pro électrotechnique et
après mon bac j'ai pas trop d'idée nous
doit faire plus tard dans ma vie et du
coup ma famille m'a parlé de du service
civique à 18 ans voyage est d'abord la
rencontre avec soi même partager ses
acquis francophone avec des jeunes prend
de suite tout son sens
on est au lycée jules ferry et c'est un
très très beau bâtiment à farah route
principale voilà des mangas a prononcé
les mots malgaches manawan voilà bonjour
au revoir à la base ben mon boulot six
animateurs langue française en tout on a
1 26 classes et
ça se passe super bien je dois faire
parler les élèves en français bon je
sais pas si ça a quelque chose à voir
avec notre culture insulaire mais on n'a
pas eu trop de problèmes
il ya une différence énorme parce qu'ils
participent déjà beaucoup plus ils ont
moins peur a parlé enfin on fait pas
trop d'illusions avec eux et et on
s'améliore mon mieux en parlant ce mois
ci avec et où le trou puisque les
français coincés ici ne parlerons ne
parle pas genre tout en français les
élèves de mon ici sont très anxieux en
chants poèmes ans
dessin en tout est vraiment c'est un
super boulot de faire ça j'adore faire
ça
cette expérience a clairement changé ces
jeunes volontaires internationaux
quelqu'un de 18 ans c'est sûr que partir
à l'étranger surtout à madagascar
travail à madagascar
c'est compliqué mais bon après on
s'habitue on est jeune et qu'on
s'habitue à tout de 300 volontaires
internationaux font rayonner le français
dans cette zone de l'océan indien depuis
ce jour là une partie des volontaires
internationaux se sont retrouvés je suis
attaché tours à l'éducation mais aussi
des enfants soutien scolaire ordinateur
culturel d'accompagner les différents
élèves dans les neuf établissements sur
madagascar qu'on est au lycée anne toile
pour l'appui à la francophonie sur
langues de france et à
fâché ferron la sensibilisation dans les
ep dans les écoles primaires publiques
et la clope de vos rêves parmi les
volontaires yoann a un beau cv après une
expérience métropolitaine il voit son
avenir dans la coopération dont je
suivais ainsi en fait volontaire en
solidarité internationale donc encadrée
par france volontaire j'étais déjà psi 2
années les deux dernières années en fait
avant d'arriver à madagascar en inde
donc j'étais coordinateur culturel pour
l'alliance française de pondichéry
une mission qui s'est très bien passé et
j'ai eu l'occasion donc voilà de de
rebondir sur une dernière année une
autre mission photo de psi
voilà à tananarive à l'oif mise à
disposition par le département à l'eau y
est façon cadre de travail est énorme
[Musique]
or noté sa capacité rapide à s'intégrer
ça c'est exceptionnel quitter son
territoire s'est retrouvé sur le
territoire dans un autre cadre
administratif et s'intégrer aussi
rapidement je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
quand il est arrivé il est allé tout de
suite dans le grand bain n'a pas et n'a
pas eu le temps de s'adapter
donc c'est une bonne chose ben non on
est très content c'est justement parce
que je suis réunionnais que j'ai pu
partir en mobilité notamment encadrés
voilà par le département aujourd'hui qui
encadre ce type de mission ce type 2
de mobilité internationale de cette zone
océan indien en fait qui est en plein
développement économique culturel
il ya énormément de choses à faire en
fait dans cette zone et la réunion a sa
carte à jouer leur carte à jouer aussi
en fait le ministère de l'europe et
celui des affaires étrangères ont
reconnu ces actions un accord-cadre sur
la promotion du français
la diversité linguistique et culturelle
et l'augmentation des échanges a été
signé le 28 juillet 2020 avec le f
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie et le département de la
réunion
la francophonie est un enjeu pour nous
tous et c'est pas seulement un ensemble
de projets que la coi peut porter la
série dont la langue d'usagé le français
avec l'organisation à francophonie avait
l' agence universal la francophonie avec
les universités de la région avec nous
ça l'exemple du conseil départemental de
la région qui s'est vraiment mobilisés
pour la francophonie dans des pays de la
zone ont seychelles à madagascar
il faut aider ces pays à rester
francophone leur jeunesse est très
nombreuse leur démographie dynamique il
faut comme le fait le conseil
départemental former des enseignants qui
vont les d'un des villages l'état où
l'organisation la francophonie ne
peuvent pas tout à eux seuls la
collectivité départementale et ainsi
résolument engagé dans le rayonnement de
la francophonie
prochainement c'est marine qui rejoindra
johan aliyev à madagascar en tant que
chargée de communication pour moi c'est
une occasion d'aller un peu à l'aventuré
de découvrir les bars les populations
qui sont proches de nous et au delà des
populations qui sont proches de nous
c'est aussi des populations dont on
monte on descend en fête est donc en
fait la coopération pour moi c'est un
peu l'avenir et c'est un peu c'est de
penser en fait cette coopération proche
de nous et cette coopération au service
de lyndiane océanie et aux services
d'aidé de la france et des réunionnais
en proximité avec les pays anglophones
et lusophones de l'afrique australe
orientale et de l'inde
la réunion département français dans
l'océan indien des toits ces visages une
sentinelle pour la faune pour comme ici
mais à voir est franchement si une
expérience à vivre
franchement c'est c'est superbe de vivre
ça
[Musique]